Netherlands World Cup squad has been released
and there's a few surprise omissions.
their 3 keepers are Justin Bailow,
Knoppert and the Rem Cold Pasphere.
so Holland aren't really blessed in the GK department.
and for that reason I'm giving them a 77 in defence,
Louise Van Harle is taking Matthias de Lyts,
Denzel Dumfries,
Terrell Malassia.
Daily Blend,
Stefan Devry,
Nathan Ackey, Timber,
Jeremy Frimpong
and the best center back in the whole competition.
Virgil Van Dyke.
so that means they're not taking Botman of Newcastle.
but I'm still giving them very good rating.
88 in midfield.
the men in orange have got Stefan Berkhosh,
Teyne Kultman,
Ash Javi Simons,
Martin the room,
Frankie de Jong,
Kenneth Taylor and Davi Kalasha
by Munich's Ryan Ravanberg doesn't make the cut.
so they've got an OK engine room.
I'm giving them and 82 in attack.
one of the star players of last season's
Champions League misses out. Dan Juma.
but you still have Luke Deiong,
Noah Lang, Steven Bergwyn,
Wald webcast, Cody Gatpo,
Vincent Yancheon and Barcelona's Memphis to pie.
like the midfields,
they're just okay.
so I'm gonna give them a rating of 82.
this gives the Holland squad an overall rating of 82.